Hawaii is a land of legends.
These old stories have existed for many years on these beautiful tropical islands.
One of the oldest legends tells of a special dance called the hula,...
...which started here more than three hundred years ago.
The hula started, as far as legend tells,...
...when Hi'iaka and her good friend Hopoe went down the beach.
Then while they were there, they noticed the waves and they imitated the waves.
And then they started to use their hands, like, you know, portraying the waves.
And that's how the hula started.
In 1820, very religious people from Western countries came to Hawaii.
They were surprised by the hula.
The dancers did not wear many clothes!
The visitors were so surprised that they asked the queen of Hawaii to ban the dance.
After that, most Hawaiians were not allowed to perform the hula for almost sixty years.
But dancers still performed the hula in secret.
Nowadays, there is a new interest in Hawaiian culture.
People want to study the culture and learn how to dance the hula.
More and more people are attending halaus.
Halaus are schools that teach the dance in the traditional way...
...with traditional values and a lot of discipline.
The dancers must work very hard to learn the dance.
They must practice for many hours before they're ready to perform the hula for other people.
Kumano Palani Kulala is a hula teacher.
For him, the dance is a way of bringing the best of ancient Hawaiian culture to people today.
The hula is more not so much a physical thing, but more of a mental and a spiritual thing.
For them the dancing means very little because for Hawaiians today,...
...many of them don't speak the language.
So, what I try to do is to bring to mind the reality that they see today.
Every year, the most important hula competition happens in Hilo, Hawaii.
Dancers from all the Hawaiian Islands come together at this festival.
It's held in the name of a Hawaiian king...
...who helped to return the hula to its place at the center of Hawaiian culture.
In the competition, judges look at more than just the dance.
They also look at the dancer's costumes and style, the way the person wears a skirt,...
...the color of their costume, even the flowers they wear.
Today in Hawaii, the hula is once again part of everyday life.
Many people hope that this will save one of Hawaii's most ancient traditions for the future.